at night is a little bit annoying you
know it's got it it's kind of operating
within its super power zone you know
with the knight jumping from squares uh
octo knight as we kind of call it
and yeah actually we might still see the
position repeat itself white using the
queen of knight together trying to get
to the black king but black's rook is
able to just kind of yo-yo back and
forth away from the attack of the white
knight then back to protect its king
away from the attack back to protect his
king and the position should still
repeat itself
i've do satoru with no time left either
so
yeah i think it now is the time to
accept the draw and magnus still begging
for that repetition in a way but he's
going to get it he's going to save this
game
and there we see now magnus leaps
forward with the knight he shrugs his
shoulders that's the third time we've
seen this position it's a draw
wow and okay well we can see both
players sort of a sigh of relief there
for magnus and the smile he did get away
with the draw here
i'm the sutter of he's not looking too
happy he was getting close to a win